cutting sandwiches with much science
with a single straight cut can you half
a three ingredient sandwich with all
components perfectly halved there's
actually real science about this called
the ham sandwich theorem and the answer
might seem obvious when you're looking
at a theoretical symmetrical sandwich
but in reality sandwiches are messy but
Mass doesn't care about messiness it
still works it doesn't matter what form
the three ingredients have or how
they're positioned imagine a slice of
bread in Munich Germany a slice of ham
at a farmer's market in San Francisco
USA and a slice of cheese in a lunchbox
and a plane to Indonesia although this
might not be a sandwich in the classical
sense there is a single perfect cut that
halves all three slices at once we just
need a very big knife and there's more
math says there's always a perfect cut
for a four piece sandwich in a
four-dimensional space same for a
five-piece sandwich in a
five-dimensional space and so on thanks
maths now any multi-dimensional
civilization can be